so we've seen our supercomputers shrink
down from the size of buildings into
devices we wear inside of our pockets
cognitive appendages that extend our
intelligence and our mind and our
cognition beyond its quotidian
boundaries right we use these tools to
reach out to one another to empower one
another in fact the United Nations 2010
development study found that the
cellphone was one of the greatest
inventions in history to pull people out
of poverty right so we create these
tools we overcome problems we overcome
boundaries but what happens when these
tools continue to dematerialize what
happens when these tools enter our
bodies and brains what happens when the
world of everyday objects gets sensors
installed into it as well people talk
about the Internet of Things people talk
about basically cognate eyes in the
world the same way we electrified it
with electricity computation
intelligence mind is just going to be
everywhere so that the normal
distinctions between self and world will
dissolve the Internet of Things is the
internet of everything which means
intelligence everywhere cognition
everywhere right intelligence turned
inside out mind turned inside out right
and all of a sudden casting its
cognitive spiderwebs all over the
reality that surrounds us so that we
start to live in our own
just like architecture has intention
embedded in its form now mind and
intention will be ever presence it will
be everywhere we will have distributed
ourselves all over this planet all over
this globe and as Ray Kurzweil says it's
only the beginning for our ability to
create virtual models in our heads our
ability to create flying machines in the
sky that further extend our cognitive
scaffolding means that in combination
with our opposable thumbs it was
sufficient to usher in this secondary
world known as technology and this
journey will continue until the universe
is at our fingertips we spilled over out
of our minds this is our triumph this is
what it means to be human
[Music]
you